Bubba Watson the PGA golfer is joining
us here in the man cave yeah part of the
125 top players in the world they off at
Liberty National Golf Club for the
Northern Trust first event of the FedEx
Cup Playoffs that's in August you got
the PGA Championship coming up as well
how are you great great great to be here
how many cars do you have B cars do I
have yeah at the house only have a
couple what do you have that's
interesting that's interesting
gosh I just got a well I just ordered a
new Tahoe but I just have a Tahoe and I
have a Chevy SS with a Corvette engine
in it they quit making them in 17 so I
have a little souped up little four-door
car that's pretty fast but do you have
cars than elsewhere like in a warehouse
no once I bought the Chevy car
dealership I just stayed with Chevy and
where I just that's well there when you
have around first car you ever had first
car I ever had to sell no mm uh 1978
sky-blue 300 D Mercedes oh yeah
wait that's pretty good yeah exactly
yeah that did it break down though nope
we we bought at a pretty good price my
dad fell in love with it and he let me
drive it and so that was my car at 16 we
were talking earlier today about
baseball home runs and the fact that
there's so many more home runs this year
they think something's launch angle on
the ball and this goes back to golf as
well launch angle angle that you come in
the golf ball itself the equipment as
well is there too much of that in golf
right now the equipment no I don't think
so I think it's just we're just we're
preparing better I'm in 97 watching
Tiger he talked about training and now
watching Tiger now it's just the science
behind everything science behind I mean
his surgery but science behind the golf
club science behind knowing the
trajectories to launch the ball but
you're not a weightlifter no but but
there's still some science without
changing your body you can change the
way you attack the golf ball because of
swing because a club angle you know all
these different things you can figure
out a way to optimize your distance and
that's what we're all doing it same as
baseball
baseball's trying to figure out they're
getting a there be able to see the
pitches a little better so they can
watch it curve a little different they
can see they're watching the angle of
his arm when he throws it things like
that so they're just you're getting
better at the sports should you start
lifting weights no if I hurt myself yeah
but you look at these guys like kepco
looks like he you know stepped out of
you know football you know the key for
Kefka is is he lifting weights or just
getting tighter shirt Mickelson gets the
tighter shirt I think Kefka is thank you
stronger Mickelson shirts are the same
is this body shape okay
yeah when Phil where's the tight shirts
like it looks good on his arms but it
it's not flattering any other place but
you know kept cos kept good looks kept
cos in the gym like he could hurt you
yeah kept kids in the gym the only thing
that kept guy doesn't do to make it to
the next level is just uh he doesn't eat
pure right like he doesn't eat the
lettuce every day but um so that would
be the only thing but yeah he definitely
tweets the shirts though I heard a rumor
no you did yeah yeah I would too if I
had that body right I would - I'm trying
to get them baggy worst body on tour
worse body on tour gosh well the one
that stands out is Phil Mickelson okay
um gosh I don't know I'm just gonna say
Phil Mickelson okay well Phil take take
that as he just put out a video and made
fun of my arms and my calves oh oh okay
we're gonna dig at him he's not here to
protect themselves but if you had guys
in shorts yeah would it look like how
would golf look if you guys got to play
play with shorts and you know goofy
shirts like we do when we play right
well you know now we're allowed to we're
allowed to play practice rounds and the
programs in shorts so there's some guys
that skip leg day you know Tiger Woods
included but Wow you know it's one of
the well he's posted on social media
you've seen him with the fish and all
the stuff and you see his legs butt and
they've got some video out there of him
wearing shorts to practice rounds so um
he does it on himself but you know
there's guys out there that you don't
want to see in shorts and so I don't
wear shorts I never I never want to
anybody see how but do you think we're
headed we're
to that to shorts no I think that
there's so much tradition but right and
so much tradition but I mean it's
already sad we're trying to call
ourselves athletes and we hired a guy to
carry our bag you know and now you're
like hey it's and now it's too hot for
us hey I need shorts so hopefully we're
not going to that point if you had an
Olympics for golfers like who is the
best athlete on tour man I'd have to add
100-yard dash
I'd say the I mean Brooks would be up
there Dustin Johnson for sure those
would be the two that stick out for sure
when you add in everything every sport
I'd have to say those are the two that I
would go for right away what if we had a
needed a starting five for basketball
Dustin Johnson we right in there Gary
woodland who played basketball in
college you know I play I mean I think I
can but your wife killed
I can shoot yeah she can definitely play
I can shoot a little bit
I'd have to say Zach Johnson can shoot a
little bit and he'd be that he'd be the
point guard so there's a few guys that
yeah you would have a you'd have a
decent squad when you get done are you
guys athletes um some of us for sure yes
there's some that are more robots I
guess you would say you know they're
beaten balls every day they're there
fine-tuning the swing there's guys that
can go without playing golf and then
show up and play and those are the
athletes those are guys with a I guess
true talent but you know Nick Faldo is
known for beating balls and having
instructors and he's six five and he's
he doesn't he didn't ever hit the ball
very far but he was a robot I mean so I
don't know if that would be Talent or if
he's trained himself to be very talented
I mean don't get me wrong he's a
hall-of-famer and won so many majors and
so many termers but he wouldn't be a
true athlete with God that big and that
build you think you hit it miles
would you rather look like foul dough or
play like Faldo oh man play like fouled
over sure we always have that debate
when uh whenever foul dough comes on the
show at Pebble whenever he leaves we go
would you rather look like that or
played the way he did well play for sure
you're a Hall of Famer and you few
majors under your belt and then you had
a good career if you could like taunt
each other like if you could trash talk
like we kind of
right well do you yeah unless you just
made fun of Phil Mickelson oh but not
we're not playing right but I'd do it if
we were playing I'd do it for sure you
would say something - Phil oh yeah I'd
say something like there's a close you
there's a close group out there right
I'd say out of the hundred and fifty
that show up at a golf tournament
there's probably 20 guys that you can
shoot the breeze with while the
competition's going on
you'll wink at them you'll you'll do
some stuff without anybody knowing what
you're doing and so there's guys you can
you can dig yet cuz they're your friends
like you know you we're out there you
know trying to play good golf we're
trying to win but if you gotta have fun
with your friends give me a golfer you
don't like you don't have to give me a
name but but wait how do I not give you
a name but a golf friend you can just
give me a story oh man it's funny there
was a story I'll give you a story okay a
guy a guy was in the ping trailer with
me when I was we were getting some clubs
tested and getting them fixed and
everything changing grips and he said he
said in a couple years I'll be selling
used cars that you would be that I'd be
selling used cars so this was years ago
because this one early early in my
career okay and it's funny because now
they're owned the car dealership I guess
he's right I guess very smart about it
but I'm playing I was one of those
things where it doesn't bother me I
don't care if you make fun of me like
that's not gonna affect me on the golf
course you know we don't have to be
friends it does you know that's not
gonna hurt my feelings and I'll give it
back the same and the first thing he
said when he said you're gonna be
selling used cars all you care about is
money you're not out here for the for
your career and trying to win
tournaments and I said you think I could
sell cars it's a pretty good business
and that's what I said back to him is I
get you're not gonna hurt my feelings
now why would Greg Norman say that right
it definitely was not Greg knew okay I
just want to make sure we get that out
say that again Greg Norman was not the
guy do you do you have Tigers cell phone
I don't have herself we'll have his
number though yeah cell phone number
right now yes yeah does he accept your
text messages sometimes
hey what happens does he block you um
he's probably blocked me before he
changes his number
quite a bit yeah and then do you have to
ask if he's changed his number since you
may not hear tonight how's that work the
real reason I try to make these team of
it here's the real reason I try to make
these team events it's because Tigers
usually when he was injured he was on
the team as a vice captain or captain or
whatever and now that he's playing and
he's making the team's that's how I get
his number
cuz you get every player's number so
y'all gonna have a group text going oh
and so even if he blocks me then I get
it that week and then I'll have it for a
little bit and I send him so many text
messages I sent in so much stuff what do
you send him by just random stuff like
hey look at this here's a bottle of
water so that might be why blocks me but
for that one week that one week when
we're on a team together I love to just
send him random stuff and he's like can
you please I thought it was pretty
amazing the number of players who stayed
after Tiger wanted Augusta yes they they
wanted to say whatever hey you know the
history of the sport and everything he's
been through and thank you and
congratulations what did it mean to you
when you saw Tiger went oh man I have a
story that I shared with him again but
um I told him years ago me and him used
to play a lot of practice rounds
together and I try to learn from I
learned by watching him so I want to
play a lot of practice rounds with him
and I told him you know we were talking
the breeze about something it was about
me winning you know I've never won a
tournament at that point when we were
playing practice rounds and we're
talking about winning and I said man I
would love to be there when you're your
next major right you're and so I I was
so focused on wanting to be there and so
when this was happening when this now
going flashing forward with all this
happening we're up in champions locker
there's a bunch of us up there a bunch
of past champions and we were like oh
we're definitely putting our jackets
only going down there and seeing them
and so that's what we did but then on my
texting my day or two later and said hey
I said I don't know if you remember this
but I I always said I wanted to be there
for you and support you because I love
you as a person not just as a golfer and
so you know and that's why when I when I
saw him coming off of 18 and he talked
to everybody shook our hands and he said
ah I'm not gonna pull you I'm not gonna
cry yet I'm not gonna
so he texts me a day later and he said
hey just let you know I cried a little
bit I didn't know who was gonna cry
first
you were tiger well I cried back in the
in the champions locker no cameras are
up there so I just now it was a it was a
thrill I mean when you talk about the
game of golf I mean what I mean what a
comeback story what a boost to the game
of golf what a moose to sports in
general so it's pretty spectacular see
that a guy go through all this stuff and
come back and play on a high level I
mean it's one away from all-time wins
record you know only I mean now we're
literally talking about he's three
majors away I mean you're talking about
to really solidify himself as the
greatest I mean he's really that close I
think he is the greatest I think he had
the greatest stretch in the history of
the game I know that you know numbers
and you know the majors but man there
was a stretch there where I don't know
if we've seen an athlete do what he did
in in you know and granted its
individual but he won like majors by 15
shots yeah like you don't that doesn't
happen yeah the the wild thing is he had
all the majors at once right Tigers play
it win it yeah I went into a different
year but I mean for an athlete to do
that I mean the highest level at all
every week if you could take one aspect
of his game what would it be mind yeah
the physical part I've always said I've
always had the physical part the
physical parts easy for me and so it's
the mental just being focused kind of
like now on this interview I'm thinking
about what I'm going to eat for lunch
you know so really I'm trying to figure
out where we're going next
yeah but not that focused if you're not
focused on me these guys are so much
funnier I'm getting ready for a major as
opposed to any other tournament so
getting ready for the PGA when's that
start you know I wanted to take a couple
weeks off because the PGA Bethpage is so
long so demanding no matter if they have
rough or not so it's not a fun course
right oh when I but it's fun because we
want to challenge ourselves as a pro
golfer but mentally and physically I
know that I need to be well rested so
that's why I want to take this week off
and next week off and my son has four
for coach [ __ ] games next week so I got
to be focused on that as well so but I
want to take some time off just so I can
get well rested and and hopefully going
there feeling fresh and and relaxed and
ready to hit high bombs because that
golf course is so demanding but if I
said you could be 18 under or you could
be 1 under what would you rather be well
no you want to be challenged no I'm
saying 101 under wins or 18 under wins
you said win so I care less okay so
doesn't matter it could be 8 over wins a
win
you know we're playing we're playing uh
gosh we playing Pebble Beach coming up
and you remember last time the US Open
there was Tiger was that well not the
last time but when Tiger won there he
was what 12 under
next was 3 over yeah I mean 2nd place
had a good battle
and then there was tie here yeah so I
mean you don't know what's gonna happen
and those kind of you know weather
situations but um but I don't care the
score I could care less the score just
weird now you you do the first day right
because you know you're trying to jockey
for position but at the end of 72 holes
if I'm winning that's all I care about
you ever screwed up a scorecard Josh not
as a professional I remember one time as
an amateur 14 years old in Dothan
Alabama in the future masters I signed
for a 5 and I'm really made a 4 that's
the only time I remember so you screwed
it up the wrong you know you know so
yeah so you have to back then you had to
take it so you get disqualified if you
went lower but you have to take the
higher score if you sign and leave we'll
leave the scoring area so I had to take
the higher score even though I made a
four so the only time I messed up I got
a golf simulator and in my man cave how
much would you charge for an hour for
you it all would be it'd be easy as long
as we could videotape it so we can watch
the and have some laughs you know all
right wait wait you don't even see my
swing yeah but I'm guessing lotta what
do you
we're the same build then we talked
about talent earlier yeah yeah
I'm a Freddie couples kind of guy so you
got a bad back yeah yeah from carrying
this show
I need more surgery than Tiger does
exactly what you got flowing hair like
Freddie yeah yeah Freddie I had that
kind of Swing right exactly nobody shows
just doesn't Freddie look like he
stepped off a yacht like he would have a
glass of wine and he said here hold this
and I'll go up and tee off yeah every
year at the Masters you see his name
it's unbelievable you see the first day
I always think Freddie's gonna be on the
leaderboard yep Bernhard longer and
Freddie couples on the leaderboard yeah
first day when we're waiting to see it
like him actually winning again at his
age you know just it just seems like
it's doable for him that I got to play
twice Augusta and the 12th was the story
I was telling these guys the 12th is so
much fun because you know we're playing
it was 149 I think when we played it and
you look at the flag on 12 you look at
the flag on 11 and you look at the trees
on 13 and I'm trying to figure out the
wind right and my caddie was the caddie
for seve when 71 mm-hmm and he said I'm
gonna hand you a club don't look at it
just swing it so the first day he gives
me a 7-iron 149 put it on the side of
the green made a birdie putt next day I
have a different caddy and then the
caddie is gone yeah I'm not sure what it
is you know and he's looking around this
caddy that I had the day before is just
shaking his head because he knows that
he's gonna he's gonna miss club he hands
me an 8 mm-hmm put it in the in the
creek and the caddy because they were
betting on us right I didn't know that
they were betting on us
I got traded on the first tee at Augusta
and I just tell these guys it is so
disconcerting when you're on 12 because
it looks harmless right but damn it
decided the Masters this year yep it
seems like it does that all the time
you got any bad stories at 12 yeah I won
the Masters and then the next year I
came back and I was top 10 I was like
ninth or eighth right in that area and
on Sunday I made at in I made about a
20-footer for a 10 on 12 so I fell off
the out of the top 10 real fast but he
was one
things I've never been so pumped for for
a 20-foot putt you know like it just
saved the day you know you celebrate
after the 20 shooter I was like man
about Elvis done with this whole you had
a 10 yeah how does that happen
yeah in the ball you're gonna be back in
New York the Liberty National Golf Club
nice view there for the Northern Trust
unbelievable you couldn't ask for a
better setting of a golf course so it's
pretty amazing what they've been able to
create there yeah
that's the first event of the FedEx Cup
Playoffs August 5th through August 11th
it's great to see again we appreciate
the last time you came in and congrats
on the success thanks for joining us as
always thanks for having me Bubba Watson
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app